it's great to welcome tom hartman back
to the program of course host of the
thom hartmann program
and author of the hidden history series
his latest book is the hidden history of
american oligarchy
reclaiming our democracy from the ruling
class
always great to have you on tom thanks
david it's great to be here with you
so let's um let's go back a little bit
as you always do in the books and talk
about the the origins of some of these
issues that still plague plague the
country today
how far back does this sort of uh
oligarchical
apparatus exist in the history of the
united states
well it goes back to uh arguably you
know
plymouth rock and slightly before um
but yeah because we fought a a a
war you know the revolutionary war
against the oligarchy of the united
kingdom
it was called a monarchy but it's just
another version of oligarchy
oligarchy being defined broadly as rule
by the rich
um the consolidation of political power
into a small number of very wealthy
hands
is sort of the political version of what
monopoly is in the economic marketplace
you know
and uh and then we you know we've had uh
this we're now in the midst of our third
real
internal challenge by oligarchs in the
uh era from the 1830s to the 1860s
uh largely as a result of the invention
of the cotton gin
uh the south consolidated massively
small farmers particularly cotton
farmers were wiped out
large plantations uh and their owners
rose up and took over the entire
political
structure of the south um declared war
on the north didn't like that pesky
democracy next door that was
you know agitating and rabble-rousing
among their ranks
and uh you know we we fought a bloody
war against these oligarchs
and and defeated them and in fact broke
up their plantations parchment is now a
state prison in louisiana robert e lee's
plantation one of the largest
is now arlington national cemetery
etcetera
so then they rose up again in the 1880s
1890s with the industrial revolution a
new generation of oligarchs
and uh to the point that uh you know in
the 1930s in the early 1933
um they tried to hire smedley butler to
uh kidnap or assassinate franklin
roosevelt they
already had enlisted over a hundred
thousand uh right-wing
veterans out of this right-wing veterans
group to march on the white house and
seize him
we overthrew that and and and roosevelt
openly said you know they hate me and i
welcome their hatred
he put the oligarchs back in the bottle
and they stayed there until the 1980s
reagan let them back out again along
with a little help from the supreme
court and today
you know we're now facing the third
major
confrontation between oligarchy and
democracy and
and uh you know this study from gillins
and page suggests
that we are now in a full-blown
oligarchy and the
the question facing america today is do
we continue going down that road
or do we go back to democracy because
oligarchies are very unstable
and oligarchs tend to oligarchies tend
to resolve themselves in one of two ways
either the oligarchs are defeated as we
did in the 1860s and as we did in the
1930s
or the oligarchs turn a nation into a
police state as victor orban has done in
hungary or putin and russia
in order to maintain their power those
are the choices we're facing right now
when it comes to sometimes what you
might call the conventional wisdom
around oligarchy which is often not
it might be conventional but it's not
necessarily accurate there's this idea
that
the biggest acceleration in this
oligarchical
overclass so to speak was during
industrialization
in part because of the ability to really
concentrate wealth
among those who could own a lot of those
factories and take advantage of the
industrialization that was taking place
is it accurate to point that as the
biggest moment of acceleration of this
or would that not be right
well technological changes um
always have massive societal impacts i
mean you know you could
you can you can find that all the way
back to the agricultural revolution the
bronze age you know the iron age the
bronze age the
uh you know the invention of steel um
etc
and and typically those kinds of changes
as the
as society gets reordered you you have a
class within society that succeeds in
grabbing as much of the pie as they can
um the uh the technological innovation
in the
in in the 1800s in the early 1800s was
the invention by eli whitney of the
cotton gin
you know the hardest part of the the
bottleneck and the production of cotton
is getting those
seeds out of a bowl of cotton they're
really hard to pull out
and the cotton gin could do what 50
enslaved people could do in the same
amount of time so the big plantations
which could afford the cotton gins were
able
you know they're 50 times more efficient
and that's how they wiped out their
small competitors
similarly in the in the late 1800s early
1900s
um you saw people like carnegie and
rockefeller
and and the dupont family and and
mr dupont i forget his first alfred
dupont no it was alfred
in any case uh you saw these guys doing
essentially the same thing monopolizing
you know the wealth and then converting
that uh
economic power into political power and
that's that's what we've seen the
billionaire class do now in the last 40
years in the united states
how do you apply this analysis to what
we've seen over the last year during
this pandemic where we've seen
when it comes to business we've seen
very large businesses that
already had certain degrees of
infrastructure in place
uh sweep up even more market share as a
lot of small businesses mom and pops and
others for a variety of different
reasons have gone under likely
permanently in the cases of
of many of them well it's
it we're we're witnessing uh a
another reconsolidation uh this time in
part because of the pandemic but also
in large part because you know in 1983
ronald reagan stopped enforcing the
the anti-trust laws in this country and
we haven't had a president since then
that
did enforce them so um you know if the
if
if the nfl said you know we're just not
going to enforce laws against
people punching each other in the gut as
they run by or ripping face mass off
pretty soon eventually you're gonna have
you know the team that's the best at
punching people and ripping face masks
off is gonna be the team that
that's winning all the games in the nfl
um that's what's happened here i mean
you know it might take a while before
you get there because everybody
you know considers it kind of
distasteful but when reagan changed the
rules of business
he really set us up on this trajectory
to where we're at right now
you mentioned the two ways that
oligarchy can go it can be defeated
or it can become the police states that
you described
orban putin etc what tends to determine
whether it goes one way or the other
the people whether the p you know
typically what
what precipitates the crisis that flips
oligarchy in one direction or the other
is is is usually an economic crisis
um and you know that's what russia is
facing right now with the
very very low oil prices which is what
their economy is
you know based on um uh with orban it
was the
syrian refugees flooding into hungary
and his and and produced both an
economic and
a a social slash political crisis and
his first the first thing that orban did
uh when he uh moved from being a
president to being an autocrat
was to say that he was going to build a
wall along the southern border of
hungary
uh to keep up the syrian refugees he
actually built that wall by the way
and uh you know and and it's amazing
there's a whole chapter in my book about
this how trump basically is following
was following orban's playbook blow by
blow by blow i mean it was just just
breathtaking and uh so you know it's a
crisis usually that precipitates that
what is it that distinguishes an
oligarch from simply a billionaire
or a multi-multi-millionaire is it a
political power component is it
something about the political system in
which they operate
generally speaking i mean you know the
the definition is subject to popular
whim
there are dictionary definitions for an
oligarch um you know
typically described as a very wealthy
person um but
but i think in the in this context and
certainly in the modern context when we
talk about oligarchs whether we're
talking about russian oligarchs or
american oligarchs or whatever
we're talking about people who have
amassed great wealth and are using
that for not only increasing their own
wealth
but seizing the political power and
process in a way that will
increase their own wealth and guarantee
the continuation of their wealth and
their political power some
might argue that the successes against
the oligarchy that we saw during the new
deal era
fdr you you mentioned that earlier in
your sort of kind of brief history of
the trajectory of this in the united
states
some might argue that a combination of
an additional many decades of
entrenchment of power
among the few in the united states
combined with
the media apparatus that's fomented by
high-speed internet
and and the sort of fragmentation of
media
um make this a very different situation
from that in which
the successes during fdr and the new
deal era took place and so
it really needs to be a different road
map for achieving maybe a similar
outcome do you agree with that that
circumstances have changed to such a
degree that the playbook must be
different
to some degree or not at all or
completely
what fdr did was uh he repudiated
the economic policies of warren harding
and calvin
coolidge and and herbert hoover those
policies were
almost identical to the ones that ronald
reagan put into place that were
confronting right now
uh when herbert hoover ran for president
his two big sales pitches were number
one
uh a return to normalcy there was a
slogan what he meant by that was
dropping that top tax rate at 91 percent
that woodrow wilson had put in during
world war one
back down to 25 which he did and
his second one was more business and
government less government
business in other words privatize and
deregulate which was reagan's agenda
at which he did and that took us to the
great depression
um the generation before that in the
1890s
um the supply ciders so-called
had this theory called the horse and
sparrow theory
which was that because back then people
you know it didn't have cars they rode
horses
and the streets in in every town in
america were filled with
horse you know piles of horse manure and
um
and sparrows love to pick you know the
occasional bit of
undigested grain out of them and so the
theory was if you feed the horses more
oats more undigested oats will come out
the back end
which will feed the sparrows in other
words give the rich people their tax
cuts
and that will trickle down to the
average worker yeah sort of a farm house
uh a farmhouse trickle down yeah
recycled now three times in the last you
know what 180 years
160 years what should the playbook be
for the people at this point in time
well what fdr did is he went back to
classic economics adam smith economics
um and and in that um you know he said
that
basically what drives an economy
is demand not supply and demand
is aggregate demand is the phrase
economists use it's it's a fancy word
that really just means wages
so if we want to get our economy back in
order
what we need to do is get money into the
hands of average people
and uh to to a certain extent that means
you know going back to to top tax
brackets
that are um substantial you know well
over 50 percent
and making sure that when people do work
they're
properly and appropriate appropriately
renumerated you know paid for that
um so you've got the 15 minimum wage
uh we need to bring back labor unions uh
which
pretty much nobody's talking about right
now but it really should be at the top
of the agenda
and strengthen workplace protections and
and worker protections right across the
board
and we need to strengthen the social
safety net we're the only developed
country in the world that doesn't
consider health care right and offer
basically free health care to everybody
we're the only developed
we're the only developed country in the
world that has medical debt as a cause
of personal bankruptcy
we're the only developed country in the
world that has student debt anything
close to what we have
um every other developed country in the
world offers either free or very
inexpensive college
to to anybody who can qualify we don't
it's insane
you know we need to we need to go back
to the foundation
you know foundational economics this was
stuff that literally thomas jefferson
was pitching he started the first free
university in the united states the
university of virginia
and was very proud of the fact that it
was completely free
he thought that would build america he
was right
it seems that one of the big propaganda
victories that the economic right i mean
going back to the time
maybe reagan forward when it comes to
these uh
supply-side trickle-down ideas one of
the biggest propaganda victories they
they've had
is pushing out the understanding of the
demand side of economics completely and
you see it even when minimum wage is
discussed you hear the discussion of
well that's going to increase costs for
the businesses and
they'll have to lay people off and they
won't be able to afford employees
it ignores which to some degree
ignores um that labor is only one
uh one input cost for the the product or
service that's being produced but it
also ignores the fact that
you're creating demand-side stimulus and
all of a sudden all of those employees
have more money that they can spend
at other businesses it's it it has been
a huge victory to completely
make it a one-sided conversation has it
not that's right
and and uh yeah you're absolutely right
and and it's not an accidental property
propaganda victory
right lewis paul laid this out in 1971 i
documented in this book on american
oligarchy
and and then nixon the next year put him
on the supreme court where he proceeded
you know in a series of decisions to
cement these policies in place
um yeah but uh and and and and groups
like the heritage foundation
and the you know the funding of
universities around the country
uh university professors in economics
and political science and things like
that
uh think tanks that are publishing
constantly i mean
do any google search on pretty much
anything that has to do
that is peripheral to the interests of
the billionaire class and you'll find
just you know the first 20 links are
going to be right-wing propaganda
it's it's really pretty breathtaking how
much money they've put into this how how
large a an infrastructure they have
built out since 1971
to promote this right-wing world view
that that really only benefits
the top one percent of americans when
we're thinking about
this nascent biden administration to to
what degree are you
optimistic if at all about uh joe biden
making good
on the promises he made specifically
with regard to this type of
wealth inequality and economic policy
that we're talking about
i'm very encouraged so far the biggest
challenge the biden is going to have is
the filibuster
and if joe manchin and kristen cinema
continue to oppose eliminating the
filibuster
um you know we're screwed uh he'll get
one or two things done by reconciliation
and that'll be it you can only use
reconciliation once or in some cases
rare cases twice a year
and uh and and then the republicans will
you know mitch mcconnell will do what
he's been doing for the last
you know a couple of decades he'll just
block everything
and uh you know we've got you know this
is why people need to call 202 224
3121 which is the switchboard of the in
the united states senate and deliver
their
opinions their thoughts about whether
the filibuster should stay or go
to joe manchin kirsten cinema and every
other
democratic member of the senate that's
202-224-3121 if you didn't write that
down real fast
and and uh you know because we've got to
end the filibuster otherwise we're
screwed
oh we've been speaking with tom hartman
host of the thom hartmann program the
newest book
is the hidden history of american
oligarchy reclaiming our democracy from
the ruling class
we we will all be watching together tom
and i always appreciate your insights
thank you david it's a real pleasure and
an honor to be on your program thank you
for inviting me